hello everyone
glad to be here in your presence an
honor to be at such a wonderful event
for such a wonderful cause today we're
going to see something that simply has
never been seen before at least I've
never seen it before
we will have the Mozart of chess Magnus
Carlsen playing a blindfold match but a
tandem three people at the same time
match against three victims let's just
call it that
Magnus needs no introduction he is one
of the greatest chess talents the world
has ever seen
at 13 years old we have a photo of him
at 13 he was already the second youngest
grandmaster in history he also drew
Garry Kasparov at the tender age of 13
and he also defeated former world
champion Anatoly Karpov at the age of 13
a little bit of a slacker well again he
needs no introduction but please welcome
one of the greatest chess players
greatest chess minds in history Magnus
Carlsen
[Applause]
now what you're about to watch Magnus do
playing three people blindfold you know
grandmasters you know I'm a grandmaster
I've done some exhibitions before I
played blindfold chest before but Magnus
is going to play a clock blindfold that
is he's going to have nine minutes total
to play the entire game against three
people that means on average he will
have three minutes per game then he will
have to defeat all these players in in
three minutes Magnus you ready for this
I never done this before I win
all right
well with that introduction let's bring
out his challengers we have three
lustrous challengers in the green room I
will tell you they all look terrified
please have a seat gentlemen we have
tables 1 2 & 3 to my far left Chris
flowers Wall Street financier he was
responsible for helping during the
crisis helping with AIG and the bailout
Chris says that his wife speaks Swedish
so if he loses today he's going to SiC
her on Magnus Chris tell us your claim
to fame
well we respect the chess I would say
it's a matter of unrequited love where I
love this game more than it loves me as
you're going to see in a minute
I I studied Magnus's games probably more
than he did study mind getting ready for
this event and and I will conclude by
saying last weekend I was with former
world champion Garry Kasparov and I
mentioned this game coming up and I
asked for his advice and there followed
a minute of silence we understand and in
the middle Paul Hoffman he is the
director of the Liberty Science Center
graduated from Harvard summa [ __ ] laude
he's a great mathematician scientist
author of many books not sure any of
that's going to help him today Paul what
is your chest claim to fame
so I met Magnus when he was 13 in 2004
he was playing for the World
Championship in Tripoli Libya and I
tried too hard to play chess with
Qaddafi and was thrown into jail so this
can't be worse indeed thought you were a
smart guy
and on the far right is Venga aqui nabe
an actor he acted on the wire 24 he's
currently on the following on Fox he
actually played a murderer on the wire
so he's ready for this I was his
preparation Benga what is your chest
claims of Fame I can find Sochi on a map
that's that's pretty much it all right
so victims to slaughter Magnus is ready
but we have to do one more step before
that Magnus has to be blindfolded so
let's welcome Alison Fornes who will
blindfold Magnus Alison in another life
is a stand-up comedian this is just to
this this is the kind of thing you know
you're getting distracted blindfolded in
the dark just before he goes to play
Thank You Alison
and I'd also like to welcome two very
important gentlemen first on closest to
you is Anatole bike offski he will be
making Magnus's moves as Magnus calls
out the moves he's also a grandmaster
and he's saying he just doesn't want to
screw this up that's all he wants and
Pascal Charbonneau who will be playing
out the challengers moves and calling
them out as well they're both miked up
the challenge here guys is Magnus will
have to keep all three boards in his
mind but not only that the clock will be
ticking it's a two-phase clock each side
has nine minutes
Magnus essentially has a third of their
time and he has to also keep track of
all the boards so the board furthest
away from Magnus is board one the middle
board is board two and this board is
board three the broad closest to us is
board three so that's all he has his
references board one bore two and board
three and he has to keep track of all
that in his head
you ready Magnus yeah let's go all right
let's see what we can do I will try to
provide some running commentary I'll be
as light as possible in my in my
comments because after all we don't want
to distract Magnus too much although
Chris promised to pay me off if I did
gentlemen let the match begin board 1e
for board 2d for board one black played
b6 b6 or d6 b minus 46 on board two
black play Knight f6 word one D for
board three C for board one black played
Bishop d7 board one Bishop d3 Bishop to
d3 on board one and board three he
played c4
a little louder please no I mean why I
was just down in the white move so black
played c5 on board too and white a black
just played a five on board three board
3G three board one black played g6 board
one c4 on board - it's your move in
black played c5 board to d5 board three
black played knight c6 board three
Bishop d2 board one black played Bishop
g7 more than one night of three board
three sorry board two black played a six
board to Knight c3 board one black
played D 6 D 6 D sick dogs a six on for
three black played f5 board one Knight
c3 and March 393 board two black took on
d5 I put e6000 or were to seat XD 5
board 1 black played be 6 board one
castles board two black played d6 pawn
to d6 board 293 board two black played
g6 board one black played h6 more to
Bishop f4 on board through three black
play Knight f6 board 3 e3
bored - it was a March 1 it was h6 right
h6 yeah bored one Bishop III
all the challengers are deep in thought
bored bored one black play Knight d7 g7
yeah bored one Queen d2 on board three
black played Bishop c5 and on board two
black played a six more three night g2e
two more to black that a six a six
apples nicks word to a four board to you
at 6:30 for Magnus 6:30 for board one
you have six thirty six board one just
play Knight to d7 board one Knight to e2
board two black played Bishop g7 board
to e3 and board three black Castle
kingside board 3d for board to blast
black Castle kingside Olson more to h3
bored three black plate eat eggs D four
more three eat XD four on that board you
have 7 minutes and 15 seconds that's
better
three challengers once again plunge deep
into thought
I'm sure Magnus is nervous wondering
when are they gonna move on board to
black played Queen c7 more to bish b2 on
board three black played Bishop b4 were
to cast mean board three castles
night bt7 or two night bd7 board two
castles
on board three black played Bishop takes
c3 more 3s yeah Knight takes c3 they say
that in chess after the first four moves
they are three billion possibilities
where it about move fifteen on every
board I don't wonder how Magnus is
keeping track on board two black played
b6 boy six more to rook e1
on were three black played d6 board
three and rookie one on board one black
played c6 board one night g3 on board
two black played Bishop d7 board one and
I mean board to Bishop c4 on board one
black played Queen to c7 board one rook
a to C one on board three rook to e8
board three Bishop g5 on board two black
play Knight to h5 for to Bishop H to
Magnus here at 5:09 on board to 550 one
on board one on board two black play
Knight to e5 board to Knight takes e5
boy three or at 6:33 black takes back on
e5 on board to with the Bishop Bishop
takes e5
on board - Queen takes e5 or to Queen b3
as a point of order if the players lose
on time they lose the game on board one
black Castle queenside that's Queen side
I was risky board one b4 on board three
black played h6 word three Bishop takes
f6 on board two black played rook F to
be 8 F to b8 be like boy 8 uh-huh makes
sense
word word - rook a to d1 on board three
black took on f6 with the Jeep on G
takes f6 board 3 Queen h5 on board one
black played King b8 board one a for
board two black played Bishop to c8
board one F for board now I mean bar -
quarter black has 2 minutes and 44
seconds on board 3 black does its bro
relevant that the position is lost board
board to black played Queen to e7
quickly soon when e as an egg serve for
two Queen c2
on board three black play Bishop e6
bored three quid g6 check on board three
you have three minutes more on board two
times about even and board one you have
three minutes more and black just played
Knight to c8 more one a five on board
too
what did you play black played Bishop to
d7 board to Queenie two both three black
Lee King to f8 board three Queen types
h6
on board one black played King to a
eight board one eight xb6 boy three
black is down to 136 you have 510 on
board one black took on v6 with the c8
night board one rook see one two a one
on board three black played King to f7
board 3d five you down to 333 on boards
on board one black played a six board 1c
v on board three black played rook to h8
board one D takes ecigs check I mean
four three three worth merge three on
board one black played night back to see
a board one Bishop Bishop takes eight a
six and on board two black played Queen
to e8
bored to Brooke
d12 a one okay on board one black played
King to be eight King to be eight
yes board one Bishop takes b7 on board
three black played King seven board 395
check metal next room on board one board
one you played Queen takes b7 board ones
he 56 on board two black played b5 more
to a b5 on board three black played King
to e8 board three Queen takes a shape
that is checkmate on board three that is
one down two to go
[Applause]
41 black played Knight takes D six award
one Bishop to f4 and on board two black
played eight takes b5 board to rook
takes a eight on board one black played
v5e five board one D takes d5 on board
two black played rook takes a eight more
to Bishop takes b5 board one black
played Knight takes e5
sorry on board one black plate Knight
takes e5 ok board one Knight takes e5
black on board one takes on e5 with the
bishop board one Bishop takes d5 board
two black played Bishop takes b5 board
to Queen takes d5 board one black played
Queen to c7 a queen to c7 board would
Queen to a two board to Queen d8 David
eight board one now I'm in bar to Queen
to d3 board one black played Queen B 77
Queen B seven boys like voice hi seven
haha board one rook to d1 it's probably
on f1 but doesn't matter Brooke you have
to do Brooke on board two black played
rook b8 like boy more to Queen d2 on
board one black played King to c7 King
to c7 yeah
board one Queen takes f7 check unlock is
down to 13 seconds of work for you black
played Queen b6 I resign
Black has design on board one you're
down to one young my rope Brooke to be
one rugby one black has 23 seconds you
have a minute and six seconds black
played Queen b3 b4
black plates e4 e5 Black has 14 seconds
Queen b6 check King edge to pawn takes
e5 f takes e5 Black has 8 seconds left
this doesn't look fun yeah Queen to d8
quick to d8 yes II 6 and the time is up
Black has run out of time
Magnus wins on all boards an amazing
display
[Applause]
it's love an absolutely incredible feat
of memory skill concentration you had an
excellent position just a couple of us
ago well that was difficult thank you
Magnus if you may please share a few
words with us was this was the first
time you've ever done this I know you've
done blindfold exhibitions before but
with the clock did that make much of a
difference as you were playing yeah it
makes it really makes all the difference
with without the clock people playing in
turn that I can do I can do a lot more
than three boards but now it was really
stressful with with a limited amount of
time but fortunately for me at some
point yeah I started to get some
advantage in the games and Paul was
doing really well but his time was
running out so he had to spend too much
time to find those good moves tell us
did you train for this at all no not
played with the clock so I've I've I
played a few lifeboats tables before but
with the clock that's that was that's a
different matter entirely did you feel
the clarity it seemed like you had total
control over what was going on in your
head explain to a lay audience what it's
like to be able to play such a match
well the thing is that you only need to
keep one game in your head at a time so
only only one game at a time but the
thing is it's it's a little bit
difficult to play but I have no idea
with my time if I'm running out of time
but you know it's it's it's manageable
for for good chess player to play to
play blind folk but really that the
target role does not allow me any time
to think the partner of mine
and that's that's really a difficult
part are you ready to take on six
challengers next time well hardly more
than Badman status title is short but
really it's it's very interesting to to
play about full chasity I know I hope
you're enjoying it
who did we enjoy it ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much for spectacular
exhibition Magnus give it up for the
Mozart of chess one of the great
geniuses of our time Magnus Carlsen
fantastic and gentlemen
thank you very much for joining us we
appreciate it thank you thank you
Magnus Carlsen for donating your time
here today at the sone Conference
Magnus's goal is to bring chess to the
world with a focus on youth when he's
not playing chess he's finding ways to
use chess as a fun tool to help make the
world a smarter place if you want to
find out how to get involved with
Magnus's work in chess and find out
about his company played Magnus reach
out to his management via his website
Magnus Carlsen dot-com